are you surprised because you know in in
uh in in law if you do something that
they're not happy with they'll take your
license away from you are you surprised
that they haven't tried to take your
license to practice as a doctor away
from you
I practice at the highest quality of
medicine possible I am fully board
certified and re-certified in Internal
Medicine and Cardiology
I am very clear on my interpretations of
the data and my reductions to clinical
practice and if anybody wants to review
my license my answer is Bring It On
because I want to review the information
with them and we'll ask which paper
which citation do they want to review
first because we have a lot to go over
Dr McCulloch um is it fair to say that
you are controversial
no you're not
um other people would disagree my
question to you is
were you controversial or did people
look at you as being controversial prior
to covid now I've never been
controversial what is getting people
uncomfortable is the truth
and you mentioned
that I'm effectively Kryptonite to
YouTube and Google
and to any of these other social media
why because it's the truth and they melt
away from it in fear if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]